ก็สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับนักเรียนสำหรับนะ
ครับจ้าจ้าโอเคกลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้กับ
น้องเตรียมนะครับในช่องคอม prensa เบิ้ล
ไทยเย้
R
ครับผมวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันกันวันนี้อ้า
วันนี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันอะไรเหรอเดี๋ยว
กลัวตี้ดูปฏิทินฮ่าๆ
ฮ่าๆวันนี้วันนี้วันที่วันนี้วันที่ 19
ครับ
วันที่ 19  9 วันอะไรวันอะไรคะ 59 วัน
อังคารหน้าอังคารใต้ครับวันอังคารที่ 19
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้ใช่ไหมครับเดือนนี้
เดือนเมษายนครับ
มีสายย่นๆปี
คศอะไรคะปีพต
265 ทับหน้า 65
[เพลง]
65 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีคศ 2000  22
2022 ใช่ครับกี่โมงแล้วครับตอนนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับอ่าพี่อาร์ตี้ดูนาฬิกาตอนนี้
13:28 น
1:20  13:28 นาเป็นตอนบ่ายแล้วใช่
โอเคครับหน้าวันนี้
บ้างคะวันนี้อ้าวอ้าววันนี้สบายดีครับแต่
วันนี้อากาศร้อนครับร้อนที่บ้านน้องเรียม
ที่บ้านนักเรียนมร้อนไหมร้อนไหม
ร้อนเหมือนกันขาวร้อนเหมือนกันว่ามันจะตก
นะอ๋อแล้วตกไหมคะ
แต่ยังไม่ตกใช่ครับบ้านเปี๊ยกพี่ก็ไม่ตก
เหมือนกันอ่ะ
อ้าววันนี้น้องเรียนจะหมดเล่าอะไรให้นัก
เรียนฟังครับวันนี้
อ๋อ
วันนี้ยังนึกขึ้นได้ว่าว่ามีหนังเรื่อง
หนึ่งอ๋อมีหนังชอบขออามิหนังพี่น้องเรียง
ชอบแล้วครับหนังเรื่องอะไรครับ
โรงเรียนคิดว่า
คิดว่าคิดว่าพี่อาร์ตี้รู้จักหนังเรื่อง
นี้ไหม
อย่างดีรู้จักมั้ยอ๋ออ๋อรู้จัก
ใส่ชุดสีดำใส่ชุดสีดำเดี๋ยวนะอย่าตีคิด
ก่อนพอมีหนังเรื่องอะไรที่ใส่ชุดสีดำบ้าง
อาชุดสีดำเหรอเฮียตีคิดถึงอ่ะ Star  Wars
อา
ซาวอเป็นดาร์ธเวเดอร์
เงินเยอะๆอ๋อพระเอกมีเงินเยอะๆใช่ไหมครับ
รวยใช่ไหมพระเอกรวยรวยมากไหมอ๋ออ๋อรวยให้
ได้นะใส่ชุดสีดำรวยมากถ้างั้นก็ต้องใส่
หน้ากากด้วยใช่ไหมครับใส่หน้ากากด้วยแสง
อากาศแบบไหนใส่นักด้วยใช่มั้ย
อ๋อโอเคถ้างั้นพี่
หาเพื่อตี้เดาก่อนเราก่อนก็ถ้างั้นเรื่อง
นี้เอ่อใช่เรื่อง BatMan ไหม
Batman มั้ยพระเอกรวยมากใส่หน้ากากสีดำ
เดี๋ยวนะอ่ะ
อ้า
ใส่หน้ากากก็ทำแบบไหนก็ทำแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
ใส่หน้ากาก
อ้าอ๋อโอเคอ่า
ถ้าตอบถูกไหมคะถูกไหมครับน้องเรียมถูก
มั้ย
ถูกต้องคะอ๋ออ๋อเป็นแบตแม้นะพี่คิดว่า
Batman เพราะว่า Batman เนี่ยรวย Batman
มีเงินเยอะจ้าใช่แล้วแบทแมนก็ใส่ชุดใส่
ชุดสีดำ
นา
[เพลง]
โอเคใส่ชุดสีดำอ้าว Batman เคลื่อนได้
มั้ยสัญลักษณ์ของ Batman ใช่ไหมครับ 5
เป็นสัตว์ตัวนึงหน้าเป็นสัตว์ที่มีปีก
แล้วก็บินได้ช้าใช่นะอ่านี่น้องเรียน
กำลังวาดอยู่
ตัวอะไรครับ
ตัวอะไรครับข้างๆๆใช่เพราะว่าเขาชื่อแบด
แมน Batman ถ้าเป็นภาษาไทยภาษาไทยเรียก
ไอ้มนุษย์ค้างคาว
มนุษย์ถังข่าวคุณน้าเป็นแบทแมน
อันนี้คือครั้งคราวๆใช้ครับค้างคาวมัน
กลับข้างข่าวทำไมถึงเป็นครั้งคราว
เลี้ยงดูในหนังเรื่องนี้ตอนแรกที่พระเอก
เป็นเด็กนะคะกับพระเอก
ตัวค้างคาว
หาพระเอกเล่นกับนางเอกที่เป็นผู้หญิง
ชื่ออะไรนะ
[เพลง]
คะเอกชื่อ 5 พระเอกชื่อ
ชายครับชื่อ Bruce  wayne
ใช้ครับ use  When  is อาหาร
เขายังเป็นเด็กเขาก็เล่นเล่นๆแล้วเขาก็ตก
ลงไปในบอกขอตกลงไปในบอกเป็น
เอ่อเอกใช่ไหมโรงเรียนบอกว่าคนนี้เป็นพระ
เอกเข้าเป็นพระเอกเนี่ยแสดงว่าต้องเป็น
ผู้ชายอ่าใช่ไหมผู้ชายจะเป็นพระเอกนะครับ
แต่ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเราเรียกพระเอก
นะครับ
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้เรียกพระเอกนะคะอ๋อถ้าผู้
หญิงไม่เรียกพระเอกแกแล้วเราเรียกอะไร
ครับ
เรียกนางเอกอ๋ออ๋อเป็นนางเอกนางเอกเป็น
ผู้หญิงพระเอกเป็นผู้ชายในเรื่องนี้โอเค
เขาเล่นกันใช่ไหมเขาเล่นกันแล้ว batman
batman ที่เป็นพระเอกพระเอกตกลงไปในบ่อ
ใช่ไหมครับตกลงไปในบ่อเออครับแล้วเป็นยัง
ไงครับ
ในบ่อนี้ไม่ได้มีน้ำนะคะพี่ยัตอิอิขออ๋อ
ไม่มีน้ำอ่ะนี่ก็คิดว่าตกลงไปในบ่อ
น้ำแต่ตอนเนี้ยอ่ะบ่มีบ่แต่ว่าในบอกไม่มี
น้ำ
k5 ขับว่าในบ่อ
มีค้างคาวค่ะอ๋ออ๋อมีครั้งคาวอยู่ในบ่อ
ครับแล้วก็เอกก็ตกลงไปในบ่อที่มีค้างคาว
อยู่ครับ
มันเหมือนแบบบ่อนี้มันจะมี
ค้างคาวอยู่ตรงนี้ขออ้าน้องเนียมเลื่อน
ขึ้นมาอีกนิดนึงครับเรื่อนขึ้นที่ทิ้งๆ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เลื่อนบอกขึ้นมาอีกครับตอนนี้ตกบ่ตกข้าง
ล่างตกขอบเค
แล้วก็เลื่อนได้แค่นี้ก็กินอะไม่เป็นไร
ครับเอามาในบ่อเป็นยังไงครับในบ่อมีอะไร
อยู่
นี่บ่พี่ก็อยู่ใต้ดินใช่ไหมคะอ๋อๆใช่
สิ่ง
ค้างคาวก็อยู่ใต้ดินตกลงไปในบ่อใต้ดินมี
ครั้งคราวๆดิน
ทั้งขวดอีคิดว่าเค้าจะบอกพอดีคิดว่าครั้ง
คราวตกใจค้างคาวกลัวกลัวที่บูธเวรตกลงไป
ในบ่อทั้งคาวอยู่ในบ่อครับตกใจบินหนีออก
มาบินหนีออกมาจากบ่อใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่อ้าโอเค
ก็
ขับวุฒิไปก็เลยกลัวครั้งคาวนะตั้งแต่เป็น
เด็กเล็กๆ
ก็เลยกลัวข้างๆเพราะว่าค้างคาวบินออกมา
ตอนที่บูธ When ตกลงไปในบอกอ๋อโอเคถาม
แล้วเป็นยังไงอีกครับอ่ะถ้าพ่อแม่ของบู๊ท
Day ค่ะครับปาร์ตี้กับต่ายตั้งแต่วุฒิ
เด็กเป็นเด็กๆเป็นเด็กๆอ้าวหรอครับพ่อน่า
เสียใจจังเลยนะฮะพ่อแม่ตายตอนที่บูธเวร
ยังเป็นเด็กๆอยู่ธรรม
ชาติหืออันนี้พ่อแม่
ของบุฟเฟย์อ่า
อายเขา
เขาโดนโจรค่ะพี่อดีตโจรโจรโจรคนไม่ดีใช่
ไหมฆ่าตาย
ครับคนไม่ดีเขาอดที่ไม่ดีเขาแบบอยากได้
สร้อยคอขออยากได้สร้อยคออยากได้เงินของ
ของแม่ของแม่ของบู๊ทถ้าไม่ใช่ไหมครับก็
เลยก็เลยมาต้นใช่ไหมต้นก็คือเอาปืนมาเอา
สร้อยมาเอาสร้อยมาถ้าไม่ให้หยิ่งถ้าไม่
ให้หญิงอ๋อโอเค
จรก็เลยยิงแม่ปิดยี่ห้อยิงแม่แล้วยิงพ่อ
ด้วยเหรอครับ
แล้วก็ยิงพ่อด้วยตายก็เลยตายได้ทั้งสองคน
เลย
ครับ
เราบูสเบสเสียใจมากเสียใจอาบคิดว่าเป็น
เองที่ทำให้พ่อก็กับแม่ค่ะอ๋อ
เพราะว่าเขาไปดูไปดูละคร
ไปดูละครในโรงหนังละคร
มีเวทีที่มีคนดู
อ๋ออ๋อแล้วบุฟเฟ่นก็ไปดูด้วยใช่ไหมครับ
ได้ขับรถ Way ก็ดูด้วยแล้วมันจะมีคนที่
แสดงเป็นครั้งคราว
แสดงเป็นค้างคาวบุฟเฟตกลัวค้างคาวอ๋ออ๋อ
ก็เลยกลัวคนที่แสดงเป็นครั้งคราวหรือ
เลยบอกพ่อกับแม่บอกว่าออกไปออกไปกู cm ก็
ไม่อยากดูแล้วบูเซ็นไม่อยากดูแล้วเพราะ
ว่ากลัวครั้งคราวก็เลยบอกพ่อกับแม่ไม่ดู
แล้วไปดีกว่ากลับบ้านดีกว่าใช่ไหมอ๋อ
จากโรงหนังก็เจอโจรไงออกโจรที่แบบมาเอา
สร้อยคอของแม่ไปแล้วก็ค่าทำก็และแม่ถ้า
ขับๆเขาก็เสียใจมากอ๋อก็เลยคิดว่า
ถึง
กับ
เขาก็เลยแบบ
เรียนจำได้ว่าที่เหลี่ยมดูเนี่ยบู๊ทมี
ตื่นขึ้นมาตื่นขึ้นมาในคุกนะคะพี่อติ
อ้าวล่ะพลังคุ้ม
ใช่
รู้เช่นอยู่ใน
อีก 1 วันเขาก็จะออกจากคุก
มีคนคนนึงอ่ะไปพูดกับเขา
เป็นพูดกับเขาว่าถ้าเกิดออกจะพูดแล้ว
ให้เดินๆไปหาไปหาดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินอ่ะ
อีดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินไหมเนี่ย
เตะอาดอกไม้สีน้ำเงิน
อ๋อดอกไม้สิแล้วก็ไปหาเขา
อีก 1 วันเขาก็จะออกจากคุก
ถามเขาก็ออกจากครัวจริงๆแล้วเพียบตีลงใน
คะว่าดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินคืออะไรหน้าคืออะไร
ครับตีไม่รู้ครับ
ทำไมต้องไปหาดอกไม้สิทธิ์กัน
ดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินเป็นดอกไม้ที่เวลาเราดง
ข้าว
เราก็จะเราก็จะคิดคิดสิ่งที่เรากลัวอ๋อ
หา
แล้วพ่นแต่ละและก็มีสิ่งที่กลัวไม่เหมือน
กันไม่เหมือนกันเน๊อะขับ
แล้วบูธเลยน่ะเขามีสิ่งที่เขากลัวก็คือ
ข้างๆๆใช่ตัวเองกลัวข้างๆๆ
ใช่เขาก็เลย
สู้สู้ๆกับความคิดที่กลัวข้างขาวๆ
จนตอนนี้
เขาก็ไปฝึกไปฝึกบนภูเขานะคะอ๋ออ๋อไปฝึก
ต่อสู้ใช่ไหมน้า
การต่อสู้บนภูเขา
หน้าเราก็
แล้วก็ก็ใช้ดอกไม้สีน้ำเงิน
ฝึกด้วย
[เพลง]
ใช้ดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินจะได้ฝึกค่าเกิดเรา
ครัวถ้ากลัวก็จะได้ไม่กลัวขอ
ถามอ่านแล้วฝึกฝึกเสร็จแล้วตอนนี้รู้สึก
เว้นก็ไม่กลัวค้างคาวแล้วใช่ไหมครับ
ไม่กลัวอ๋อโอเคขับ
ต่อว่า
ก็จะมีคนที่ที่คลิปคิดไม่ดีกับเมือง
ก็อธแธมนะคะอ๋ออ๋อเมืองก็อธแธมที่ Bruce
wayne อยู่นี้ใช่ไหมครับ
เขาคิดไม่ดียังไงครับเมือง
หน้าเมืองกอดห้ามชายเขาคิดนี่คิดไม่ดียัง
ไงครับ
คิดไม่ดีคือเขาคิดว่าที่เมืองกอดแทนมีคน
คน
ไม่ดีเยอะๆอ๋อก็จะคิดว่าจะฆ่า
คนเยอะๆเขาต้องการที่จะฆ่าคนที่ไม่เต็ม
ที่ใช่ไหมครับอ๋ออ่าแล้วแล้วก็ทำยังไง
ครับ
เขาก็ใช้ดอกไม้สีน้ำเงิน
ไม้เสียง
เอามาเทลงในท่อระบายน้ำ
ใต้ดินก็จะมีท่อระบายน้ำ
ครับเขาก็เอาดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินที่เป็นน้ำนะ
คะครับน้าดอกไม้เสียง
อ้ามาทำเป็นน้ำแล้วใส่มันไปในท่อระบายน้ำ
เพื่อให้คนเพื่อให้คนที่อยู่ในเมืองนั้น
ดื่มน้ำเข้าไปใช่ไหมครับ
เขาก็ทำเป็นควันนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ๋อ
วันมันจะมีเครื่องเครื่องมือมีเรื่อง
ที่ทำควัน
ขับรถในเมืองก็จะมีปันเยอะๆเวลาคนลมอื่น
ฟันเข้าไปแล้วเขาก็จะกลัวจะเห็นคนก็จะ
เห็นเห็นสิ่งที่ตัวเองกลัวใช่ไหม
อ๋อใช่แล้วก็จะค่า
อ๋อผู้คนก็จะฆ่าคนก็จะฆ่ากันแล้วก็ตาย
หลายๆคน
ใช่
R5 แล้วแล้วเป็นไงครับแล้วเป็นยังไงตอบ
batman  batman รู้ไหมรู้หรือไม่รู้ครับ
รู้ค่ะ Batman รู้เลยจะมาช่วยอ่ะค่ะรอ
ครับช่วยเขาก็ต้องใส่ชุดสีดำใส่หน้ากาก
อ๋อไม่อยากให้คุณสิเอาเอง
โทรหาเขา Batman ไม่อยากให้คนรู้ว่าเขา
ไม่อยากให้คนอื่นรู้ว่าเขาคือ Bruce
wayne ไม่อยากให้รู้ฮือก็เลยใส่หน้ากาก
ใช่ไหมครับเหรอ
ๆ
มันจะมีคนหนึ่งที่เขาเอาเอาเครื่อง
เครื่องทำควันใคร
ไปบนรถไฟ
ขอกินบ้านรถไปครับเครื่องทำควัน
ขึ้นไปบนรถไฟจะเอาไปใส่ในน้ำใช่ไหม
ก็จะใช่ค่ะจะเอาไปใส่น่าจะไปใส่น้ำ
โอเคอ่านี้เป็นรถไฟ
เข้าเครื่องทำควันขึ้นไป
เราก็จะเอาไปในที่ที่มีท่อน้ำ
หัว
ข้อน้ำใหญ่ๆ
อันนี้คือท่อน้ำนะครับ
อะไรจะมีน้ำอยู่
แล้วรถไฟเขาก็ต้องวิ่งบนรางรถไฟใช่ไหมคะ
พี่ใช่ใช่
ทางรถไฟก็เลยจะไประเบิดรางรถไฟขอใครจะไป
ระเบิดรางรถไฟครับ
มันจะมีตำรวจอีกคนนึงค่ะ
ตรวจที่เป็นคนดี
อาหารเป็นคนดีเป็นคนดีจะไปอาจจะไปหยุดไม่
ให้คนไม่ดีเนี่ยที่จะเอาอ่าควันที่มีดอก
ไม้สีน้ำเงินไปใส่น้ำเนี่ยตำรวจก็จะไปไป
ไปต่อสู้ไม่ให้เอาไปใส่โอเคอ่า
ว่าแล้วต้องรีบมาทำอะไรครับหรอตำรวจมา
ระเบิด
กลับมาเป็นยังไงบ้างครับไประเบิดรางรถไฟ
หน้าระเบิดได้ไหมระเบิดสำเร็จไหมครับ
สำเร็จค่ะตอนคล้ายล้างรถไฟก็ขาดขอเออพลัง
รถไปขาดรถไฟก็วิ่งไม่ได้นะ
หาออกใหม่ดีรถตกลงไปครับ
ลบคน
คนที่ไม่ดีก็ตายอ๋อ
ในภาคที่ 1 นะคะครับมีภาคขึ้น
ว่าภาพที่หนึ่งอ้ะมันทำให้คนที่อยู่ใน
กรุ๊ป
คนไม่ดีที่อยู่ในกูอ่ะ
เป็นคนไม่ดี
คนไม่ดีออกมาจากคุกได้หลายๆคนอ้าวหรอครับ
ราคาพอทำไมถึงออกมาได้ให้ครับ 5 อยู่ใน
โคราชคนที่ไม่ดีถูกตำรวจถูกตำรวจจับไป
เข้าคุกแต่ตอนนี้ตอนที่ตำรวจไปไปช่วยป้อง
กันรถไฟคนที่อยู่ในคุกก็หนีออกมาจากคุก
ใช่ไหมหนีออกมาจากคุกหมอ
ครับมีใครหนีออกมาบ้างครับ
หนึ่งในคนไม่ดีคนไม่ดีหนีมารหลายๆคนห้ามี
คนนึงคนหนึ่งเป็นใคร
ครับชื่อเอออ๋ออ๋อ
Joker กวนตีหลุดจากโจ๊กเกอร์โอเค Joker
หนีออกมาจากในคุก
อ่าโอเคอ่าแล้วยังไงต่อครับ
แล้วค่อยไปกันต่อเนื้อผ้าหนาอ้าวแล้วก็จบ
โอเคก็ตอนนี้เอ่อน้ำน้ำในเมืองก็โอเคไม่
มีไม่มีดอกไม้สีน้ำเงินในน้ำคนก็โอเคเรา
ก็แต่แต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย Joker หนีออกมาจาก
Miku แล้วแนนเดียวคราวหน้าคราวหน้า
เดี๋ยวอ่าน้องเรียมแล้วจะมาเล่าต่อเนื้อ
เรื่อง BatMan นะครับที่จะ Batman จะทำ
ยังไงกับโจ๊กเกอร์ที่หนีออกมาจากคุกนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาติดตามกันใช่ไหม
ครับจัด
r&k เวลาแล้วอ้าใช่ขับรถเวลาคาแล้วครับ
เดี๋ยวมาฟังกันต่อนะครับกับ Batman ใน
ครับจากน้องเรียมข้าวหน้าครับวันนี้ครัว
ตี้แล้วก็น้องเรียมลาไปก่อนครับนักเรียน
ครับผมอ่ะสวัสดีครับแล้วพบกันใหม่นัก
เรียนจะครับนั้นโรงเรียนบ๊ายบาย